[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
without telling us the verdict juror
number four do you believe the jury has
reached a unanimous verdict that's to
all
[Music]
verdict accounts in this case a verdict
is handed down in a double homicide
trial for colorado defendant kevin dean
eastman and the parents of the accused
oxford high school shooter filed an
appeal arguing their case should be
thrown out plus a parkland school
shooting survivor describes what
happened moments after he fled from the
school nick cruz
came and sat down right next to me but
first the murdoch murder mystery let's
say
richard ellen murdoch are you guilty or
not guilty of the felonies wherein you
stand and die
not guilty law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmark alec murdoch
the disgraced south carolina attorney
accused of murdering his wife and son
pleads not guilty to the charges law and
crime correspondent angela levy is here
with what happened in court anjanet
brian alex murdoch appeared in court
alongside his attorneys to enter those
not guilty pleas to the murders of his
wife maggie and son paul now burdock
murdoch rather looked noticeably
different the former attorney is now a
defendant of course he wore handcuffs
street clothes and his head was shaved
prosecutors in colton county south
carolina say murdoch used two guns a
rifle and a shotgun to murder paul and
maggie on their hunting estate in june
2021. the crime shocked the community
alex murdoch comes from a prominent
family and is part of a legal dynasty in
south carolina murdoch answered
questions during the arraignment
richard murdoch if that is your name
please raise your right hand
do you wave reading of the indictments
yes sir
what say you richard ellen murdoch are
you guilty or not guilty of the felonies
wherein you stand and die
not guilty how shall you be tried by god
in my country
now alex murdoch and his lawyers did not
object to him being held without bail on
these murder charges he already had a
seven million dollar bond in place for
another case involving fraud allegations
uh that stem from how the estate of his
late housekeeper gloria satterfield was
handled murdoch is also facing charges
in a plot to take his own life so his
son buster could collect the life
insurance money brian
thanks angenet joining today is former
swat and detective lisa lockwood and
co-host terry austin lisa new murder
charges against the now infamous murdock
with all that he's facing were these
charges expected or a surprise to you
they were expected the only thing is i
didn't expect it so soon it's been a
year since the deaths of maggie and paul
the wife and the son of mr murdoch
and all they have right now is
circumstantial evidence and because it's
circumstantial it takes a while to build
the case and it's slow and it's a
methodical process so
yes i expected it surprised at how early
they did it but it seems that they have
enough yeah well terry the defense
attorney did not fight to have bail
imposed or set in this case and the
judge agreed why do you think the
defense did that
you know i think the defense knew it was
futile to argue for a full release on
his own recognizance and you might as
well make a good faith gesture and agree
to impose some amount of bail here and i
think obviously for bail there are
multiple considerations so flight risk
harm to self-harm to others the risk
that he'll commit another crime and if
you ask me here in this case all of
those exist so there's going to be bail
the question is how much you might as
well agree to it yeah well anjanette
tell us about the agreement the
prosecution of defense announced at the
hearing
well brian it was pretty interesting a
lot of times you'll see in high profile
cases attorneys on both sides will agree
not to discuss the case publicly and
that was part of one of the
agreements that was announced in court
no extrajudicial statements also they
agreed to file a lot of the motions
under seal
so that agreement is in place as well
also the judge said you know obviously
you can do that but anything that's
discussed in open court is fair game
which we all know and then an
interesting comment by dick carpoolian
one of the attorneys for alex murdoch he
said that basically murdoch wants to put
this behind him
and hopes that law enforcement can find
the real killers so we've kind of heard
that type of thing before o.j simpson
most notably said when he was acquitted
he wanted to help find the real killers
of his wife nicole his ex-wife nicole
and her friend ron goldman all right
interesting arguments there we'll see
how that case develops as it continues
in the murdoch murder mystery and six of
the 13 turpin children who were rescued
from a life of captivity in their
parents california home in 2018 are
filing a lawsuit alleging severe abuse
after they were placed in foster care
david and louise turpin abused their 13
children for years until 2018 when their
daughter jordan managed to escape she
told officials her brothers and sisters
who ranged in age from 2 to 29 had been
starved and sometimes changed to their
beds authorities subsequently learned
the terpenes had deprived their children
of hygiene education sleep health care
and more the children were virtually
isolated from the world some for decades
in what the media dubbed a house of
horrors david and louise pled guilty to
more than a dozen felonies and were
sentenced to life in prison
unfortunately that's not where the abuse
ended a new report released this month
discover the siblings received poor care
after they were rescued the lawsuit
against the county and 50 unnamed
defendants alleges some of the children
were sexually abused and that they were
placed with abusive caregivers for three
years who were later charged and
arrested for crimes stemming from the
alleged sexual and physical abuse of
foster children
still ahead on law and crime daily the
accused oxford school shooter's parents
say their case should be thrown out
before it goes to trial but first a
parkland school shooting survivor takes
the stand where he ran into the shooter
just minutes after the massacre
[Music]
welcome back we turn now to florida for
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial on thursday a survivor
testified he ran into the gunman after
the shooting not knowing he was the
culprit 17 people were killed and 17
more injured when a then 19 year old
gunman opened fire at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in 2018. in october
of last year the shooter pled guilty to
17 counts of murder and 17 more counts
of attempted murder which prompted his
case to head straight into the penalty
phase it's now up to a broward county
jury to decide whether the shooter is
sentenced to life in prison or given the
death penalty on thursday survivor john
wilford took the stand he described
fleeing for a mcdonald's restaurant
after the shooting where the shooter sat
down next to him wilford later found out
he was the school shooter who had shot
and injured his sister
he just sat down i didn't think much of
it you know he was just
i figured he was from school because of
what he was wearing but what was he
wearing
uh
rotc uniform okay
so what happened then
from then i wasn't really
i mean i saw him sit down so i just was
telling him you know like this is so
chaotic you know this is crazy all these
helicopters and swat cars coming like
what do you think this could be and
um i don't remember him saying much but
he was just
head down wasn't really talking to me i
don't remember much of the conversation
but
i was doing most of the talking okay did
he ask you anything
uh
no not until i started to leave when my
mother uh
called me and told me that she was there
okay
what did he ask you
he
asked me for a ride
when i was like starting to leave
the mcdonald's to
meet my mother on the other side that's
when he
started talking to me okay and what did
you say
uh he asked me for a ride
um
he was pretty insistent on it and i said
no
i just
i wasn't really thinking
much of it i mean i was just trying to
get home my sister wasn't answering her
phone i was
nervous i was panicked i didn't i also
had a bad
gut feeling about it it's good that he
had that bad gut feeling terry as we
hear from more and more witnesses what
is the image you think the jury is
getting of the parkland shooter
well it's interesting because i think
the image is exactly what the
prosecution wants that jury to have of
this defendant he has those seven
aggravating factors and i think he's
proving it all with the witnesses that
he's putting on that stand so one of the
aggravating factors is the fact that the
murder was heinous atrocious and cruel
and absolutely it was the fact that the
you know shooter could come out and sit
next to someone whose sister was injured
or in the event and so i definitely
think that he's showing that this person
really has no feelings at all whatsoever
it was cold and calculated i think that
the prosecution is showing that very
well too and it was a governmental
function that's one of the other
aggravating factors it was at a school
so i definitely think that part of what
the prosecution's design here is to make
sure he ticks off all of those seven
factors here and you know it was a risk
of death to many of course we know for a
fact 17 dead 17 injured so i think the
jury's coming away with a feeling that
this person is a horrible individual and
all of those aggravating factors will
probably apply yeah the prosecution
definitely is methodically going through
that list that you uh so well put out
for us there terry now lisa i'm assuming
as a former detective you've sat across
the table from a number of suspected
killers how difficult must it have been
for wilford once he knew who he was
sitting across from
well in the job that i had obviously the
element of surprise was really never
there you just always suspect the horse
when you're dealing with criminals in
this particular case he thought he was a
student he was wearing rotc attire he
thought he was part of it the only thing
that was peculiar is that he pulled up
and sat across from him and then became
adamant about getting a ride but good
thing wilford had the the gut instinct
and i always say trust it trust your gut
when something feels off and he did he
told him no i'm going to decline the
ride and that was it and he left so i'm
sure seeing that video of himself in the
aftermath probably was very very eerie
for him yeah especially with the
connection with his sister i think the
clip we showed there was a sister in the
audience we would probably expect her to
testify as well
well in colorado ring doorbell footage
catches a suspect in the act after
pointing a gun at a couple who he
followed home law and crime reporter
sierra gillespie has the story
it happened on july 15th about 20
minutes west of denver colorado a couple
there says they were walking home when a
man and woman started following them
after that the suspects followed the
couple home where the male suspect
pointed a gun at their faces that's when
the couple ran inside and slammed the
door
investigators say minutes after the
suspect sped off they robbed another
person at gunpoint
after releasing the video investigators
say they arrested the male suspect who
they say was wearing a wig at the time
coming up on law and crime daily a
verdict is handed down in the trial of
colorado versus kevin dean eastman plus
jennifer and james crumbly say they
aren't at fault in the oxford high
school shooting could their case be
dismissed
[Music]
welcome back parents of the accused
oxford high school shooter filed an
appeal saying their involuntary
manslaughter charges should be dropped
completely in an appeal filing this week
jennifer and james crumbly argue they
never should have been charged in the
first place court documents argue that
crumbly parents should not be held
accountable for the choices and actions
of their son saying they had no idea he
would carry out the deadly attack in
november of last year the gunman opened
fire at oxford high school four people
were killed and eight others injured the
then 15 year old suspect was arrested
and charged with multiple counts of
first-degree murder and terrorism
jennifer and james crumley were later
charged for failing to secure the weapon
used in the attack
just last month a michigan judge ruled
the suspect's text messages and journals
could be used as evidence in the parents
trial right now that trial is still set
for october of this year
terry do the crumbly parents have an
argument as to why their case should be
thrown out or is this a a hail mary of a
request
oh brian i definitely think this is a
hail mary of a request what i will say
is that these charges are very unique
it's very rare that we see the parents
of a child getting charged in connection
with that crime but here i think the
prosecution made the right decision
they're being charged because they are
culpable the fact that they knew he had
mental illness issues they knew he had a
gun they knew he had ammunition they
completely and totally ignored what the
school was trying to convey to them in
terms of what they saw him doing the
drawings that they saw the clues that he
gave in terms of you know wanting to
kill small animals so i definitely think
that the parents should be held
responsible for this it's a unique set
of circumstances and i do think that you
know of course they're going to try to
have the case dismissed against them but
i think it's a hail mary i don't think
the judge is going to allow that to
happen at all yeah i like the fact that
you use the word unique because that's
kind of my question for lisa as to how
unique this is because lisa the crumbly
parents are the only parents being
charged in a mass shooting but there are
some similarities in the highland park
shooting do you think in that case the
shooter's father could be charged
well if we're using the precedent that
we're using right now in this particular
case i would say yes it fits the
criteria
they ignored help for uh his mental
health issues we had april of 2019 he
attempted suicide with machete police
went there they took away his knives and
his daggers then let's fast forward to
september of 2019 where he threatened to
kill his whole family and again no
charges were pressed these are mental
health issues and then we have december
just three months later where father
goes and co-signs and sponsors him to
get a foid card who in their right mind
is going to do that for a son who in the
same year attempted to kill himself and
the family now let's go buy him a gun to
me that does fit the criteria for
involuntary manslaughter yeah and lisa
it's not just what you said it's what's
missing as well in my mind because if
all this happens did you get your son
help in between a social worker uh
psychiatrist anything you're just like
ah it's three months ago let's just buy
you a gun like that is bewildering to me
but we'll see how the cords think of
that one well when we come back a jury
hands down a verdict in colorado as
kevin dean eastman faces a possible
sentence of life in prison for a 2020
double homicide
welcome back to law and crime daily a
colorado man is sentenced a day after
the jury found him guilty of a double
homicide in the trial of kevin dean
eastman
late wednesday night the judge announced
eastman was found guilty on all charges
including two counts of first-degree
murder tampering with a deceased human
body and tampering with physical
evidence for the deaths of his
ex-girlfriend heather frank and her new
love interest local musician stanley
scott sessions in february of 2020.
prosecutors say eastman cut session's
throat after inviting him over to
frank's apartment using her cell phone
eastman and frank were charged in his
murder until it was discovered frank had
also been killed investigators believe
eastman fatally shot frank to silence
the only witness to sessions killing
prosecutors allege eastman burned
session's body before frank's body was
discovered wrapped in plastic hidden on
the rule property of his new job
investigators say he was preparing to
burn her body as well before being
arrested at a nearby gas station
the verdict was handed down seven hours
after the jury began their deliberations
dispensing with the caption as relates
to count number one
murder in the first degree involving
victim stanley scott sessions the
verdict reads we the jury find the
defendant kevin dean eastman guilty
of murder in the first degree after
deliberation
as it relates to count number two
murder in the first degree involving
victim heather frank
the verdict reads as follows
we the jury find the defendant kevin
dean eastman
guilty of murder in the first degree
after deliberation
the jury further found that this was an
act of domestic violence we the jury
find the defendant kevin dean eastman
guilty of tampering with a deceased
human body we the jury find the
defendant kevin dean eastman
guilty of tampering with physical
evidence
on thursday eastman learned his sentence
after being convicted of murder
what i will say
mr eastman is that you are going to
spend the rest of your
natural life in prison
based on your
vicious acts of violence
jealousy and control
and the taking of two precious lives
and thereafter disposing of
their deceased bodies in such a
disrespectful manner that's why you're
going to spend the rest
of your life
in prison the court is going to sentence
you
to
a life sentence in the colorado
department of corrections
without the possibility of
pearl
all right so lisa clearly the jury
didn't buy that bonnell and frank were
in on these murders why do you think
that was
because simply was a ludicrous defense
what did bonnell what skin in the game
did he have to
help bury the bodies get rid of the
bodies and then
say later on that he also killed frank
because he panicked there's no motive
for him to do this it was a hail mary
pass it didn't work they didn't buy it i
think anybody that was watching the
trial thought oh wow that's a real a
really far stretch for him to blame his
former co-worker
for the whole kitten caboodle for
killing his wife and for killing
sessions it didn't make sense at all
what i will say this is a great teaching
moment in terms of what's the difference
between a doubt and a reasonable doubt i
don't think the jury found this to be a
reasonable doubt anything can be a doubt
and it wasn't enough to carry the
defense's case well terry why is the
sentencing being done so soon i mean
typically this happens weeks sometimes
months afterwards and did the time uh
with the time life without parole
fit the crime in this double homicide
it definitely fit the crime brian and in
colorado if you are convicted of a crime
of violence that carries a mandatory
prison sentence meaning that the judge
has no choice but to sentence you to
prison so the judge can increase the
sentence but he can't reduce it but here
he was convicted of first degree murder
in colorado first degree murder is life
life is life so i think the judge just
decided look i don't think i'm going to
change my mind here nothing is going to
change the decision
and he wanted to get it over now
obviously there could be you know victim
impact statements but the judge had
already made up his mind that he was
going to do life life without parole and
so that's exactly what he did he didn't
think there was a reason to hold it over
makes sense why there was no delay in
that and just kind of move right forward
well lisa terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you